one of them was heating up in theaters  yes what happened here a crew exploring  a distant planet makes an unimaginable  and terrifying discovery in alien  covenant holy the great athlete road  trip Diary of a Wimpy Kid the long haul  sense a Heffley family hilariously  off-course  this is my whole world I'm 18 and I've  never been outside a teen with a rare  disease Falls for the boy next door in  everything everything I'm willing to  sacrifice everything to live one perfect  day see with hot in theaters with this  week's anticipation so what's your  weekend to get going to be let us know  by commenting see you next time on  weekend ticket  you  [Music]